[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguna vez te has planteado qué
ocurriría si tu país literalmente
comenzará a extinguirse es decir si su
población entrará en declive la gente
cada vez fuera más mayor empezar a
escasear la mano de obra y muchos
colegios pueblos y barrios y fueran poco
a poco quedando vacíos pues queridos
amigos y amigas de visual político ese
es más o menos el proceso que ya se está
experimentando en japón el país más
envejecido del mundo fijaos
[Música]
a día de hoy 1 de cada 4 japoneses
tienen ya más de 65 años representan el
28 7 por ciento de toda la población
nipona para que os hagáis una idea en la
unión europea a otro territorio con
muchos problemas de envejecimiento
demográfico que este porcentaje apenas
supera el 20 por ciento en otras
palabras si todos los japoneses con más
de 65 años formas en su propio país este
tendría aproximadamente la población de
polonia o canadá además japón es el país
del mundo con más personas centenarias
aproximadamente 80.000 japoneses cruza
la barrera de los 100 años
y de hecho para muchos expertos el
proceso que se está viviendo en japón no
es más que un adelanto de lo que le
espera a buena parte del mundo
desarrollado en apenas unas pocas
décadas precisamente por eso japón puede
convertirse en todo un campo de pruebas
sobre cómo afrontar los retos que
conlleva la inversión de la pirámide
demográfica y ojo porque no hablamos de
ninguna broma esta cuestión puede poner
en jaque todo el modelo económico y
social de nuestros países y justo aquí
es donde nos surgen unas cuantas
preguntas exactamente de qué retos
estamos hablando cómo podemos evitar que
nuestros países y sociedades
languidezcan al compás de una población
cada vez más y más envejecida cuál está
siendo la experiencia de japón cómo
demonios el país del sol naciente se ha
convertido en el país más anciano del
planeta tierra pues bien en este vídeo
vamos a tratar de dar respuesta a esta y
otras preguntas pero antes antes me
gustaría haceros una recomendación
y
no sé si ya la ha visitado un vistazo
pero si no os lo recomiendo
encarecidamente si lo hubiera sabido el
nuevo canal de actualidad financiera que
ha lanzado mucho activos y con el que el
equipo de visual polític colaboramos es
un canal cuyo objetivo es hacernos
llegar la mejor información sobre las
principales tendencias que mueven las
bolsas echadle un vistazo y ya nos
contaréis qué os parece pero dicho esto
arranquemos
[Música]
una combinación explosiva
amigos amigos de visual político por lo
general ya sabéis que no somos muy
amigos de bombardearnos con datos pero
en esta ocasión para poder entender lo
que de verdad está sucediendo en japón
hay algunos números que tenemos que
tener muy en cuenta hablamos de un país
con las peores proyecciones posibles en
términos de envejecimiento para que os
hagáis una idea para el 2036 se estima
que los mayores de 65 años supondrán ya
casi el 35 por ciento de toda la
población al mismo tiempo la tasa de
fertilidad que comenzó a caer en los
años 70 cada vez se aleja más y más de
la tasa de reposición demográfica que se
sitúa en dos como un hijos por mujer
pues bien en japón actualmente esta
cifra a duras penas supera los 1,4 hijos
por mujer una de las tasas más bajas de
todo el mundo aunque hay que decir que
en esta cuestión los surcoreanos se
llevan la palma fijaos
y claro el cóctel explosivo formado por
cada vez más ancianos y cada vez menos
niños conduce irremediablemente a una
cosa la contracción de la población
de hecho desde el año 2011 la población
japonesa no ha dejado de reducirse tan
sólo en 2020 la población del japón se
redujo en casi 400.000 personas durante
ese año 38 de las 47 prefecturas del
país perdieron habitantes y de hecho se
espera que la población de japón pase de
unos 126 millones de habitantes en 2020
al entorno de los 111 millones en 2040 y
mucha atención a poco más de 87 millones
para el 2075
es decir en poco más de 40 años japón
perderá más del 30% de sus habitantes
hablamos de una contracción demográfica
sin precedentes japón se cae del top 10
de países más poblados censos de 2020
amigos tal y como os podéis imaginar
este tipo de cambios demográficos
conllevan importantes implicaciones en
todos los ámbitos del país incluida por
supuesto la economía se prevé que la
población en edad laboral se hundan
japón y corea del sur- un informe de la
ocde ha calculado que para 2050 la
población en edad laboral de japón habrá
disminuido al 61 8% en relación a la
población que habría en el año 2000
llegados a este punto seguro que la
mayoría de os estáis preguntando vale
vale enrique pero cuáles son las causas
que detrás de todos estos malos datos
que parte de responsabilidad de la
sociedad de la cultura y qué parte luís
de las políticas
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
un país que se extingue
en el mundo aún son muy pocos los países
que ya están experimentando el declive
demográfico corea del sur y japón son
hoy por hoy dos de los casos más
destacados pero porque que factores
están contribuyendo a este escenario nos
vamos a centrar en el caso de japón pero
la situación es con el sur es muy pero
que muy similar pues bien el caso es que
vamos a poder encontrar causas y
factores vinculados con el aspecto
social y cultural por un lado y por otro
con el económico y político si os parece
vamos a empezar echando un vistazo a los
primeros amigos el mercado laboral
japonés es probablemente uno de los mas
anticolonización familiar que existen en
todo el planeta los japoneses tienen que
lidiar con larguísimas jornadas
laborales que a menudo pues dejan poco
espacio para plantearse siquiera formar
una familia
además en el caso japonés solicitar
bajas médicas o permisos de maternidad o
paternidad es algo que no está muy bien
visto y que puede tener consecuencias
profesionales digamos que a pesar de que
la ley japonesa reconoce bajas de
maternidad remuneradas de 36 semanas el
país se encuentra a la cabeza mundial en
materia de derechos de paternidad con 30
semanas las barreras culturales siguen
pesando mucho por ejemplo y para que os
hagáis una idea a pesar de lo
establecido por la ley
los hombres que solicitan bajas de
paternidad remuneradas siguen siendo una
minoría y por lo general a duras penas
las solicitudes llegan a las dos semanas
de permiso la mitad de lo reconocido
legalmente
[Música]
otro factor social que afecta a las
tasas de natalidad es la tendencia cada
vez más clara de los japoneses a no
formar pareja según los últimos datos
disponibles en el país del sol naciente
más del 35 por ciento de la población
vive sola cada vez son más y lo que es
más sorprendente muchos japoneses ni se
preocupan en tener pareja vamos que si
quieres ligar no tengo que ver o seguir
a japon es una muy buena o una pésima
idea no lo sé
[Música]
luego los números nos dicen que ya sea
por motivos culturales o económicos los
japoneses están teniendo muchos pero que
muchos problemas para adaptarse al
cambio del mercado laboral y es que
veréis tradicionalmente el mercado
laboral japonés se ha caracterizado por
los empleos estables la cosmovisión
general pasaba porque si un trabajador
se esforzaba pues podría permanecer en
la misma empresa toda su vida mejorando
progresivamente sus condiciones
laborales por supuesto este tipo de
empleos conocidos en el país como
trabajos regulares vienen cayendo en
picado desde los años 90 por ejemplo tan
sólo entre los años 1995 y 2008 el
número de trabajadores regulares cayó en
3,8 millones mientras que los empleos
temporales y freelance crecieron en 7,6
millones y sabéis que nos dicen los
datos pues que de todos los trabajadores
temporales sobre las apenas el 30% de
los que están en la treintena están
casados esto supone para que os hagáis
una idea casi la mitad que los
trabajadores regulares con la misma edad
así que en este caso la precarización o
la menor seguridad percibida sí que
podría estar teniendo como veis una
influencia muy pero que muy importante
evidentemente a más solteros pues menos
hijos ahora bien muchos puede que os
estáis preguntando vale vale enrique
pero si faltan hijos y faltan
trabajadores por qué no fomentar la
emigración
[Música]
y ojo que esta es una cuestión muy
relevante en países desarrollados la
llegada de población del extranjero no
sólo ha permitido mantener o ampliar la
masa laboral sino que también ha
contribuido a elevar las tasas de
natalidad sin embargo frente a gioja
pont es quizás uno de los países más
restrictivos de todo el mundo en junio
del 2019 por ejemplo apenas el 2% de la
población de japón eran residentes
extranjeros hablamos de menos de 3
millones de personas por comparar españa
un país con tres veces menos población
tiene casi el doble de inmigrantes cinco
millones y medio un 11,4 por ciento de
sus habitantes
[Música]
evidentemente esto tiene sobre todo
explicaciones políticas hasta 2018 la
legislación migratoria japonesa sólo
otorgaba la residencia legal con derecho
a trabajar a profesionales altamente
cualificados profesionales en programas
de formación procedentes de países en
desarrollo y estudiantes bajo ciertas
condiciones en la práctica las visas
eran propiedad de la empresa y estaban
directamente ligadas al contrato laboral
es decir si la empresa prescindía de ti
te tenías que ir del país
así de simple desde 2018 y tal y como ya
os hemos contado en vídeos anteriores se
ha introducido más flexibilidad por
ejemplo se han creado dos tipos de
categorías de imigrantes laborales la
primera permite a trabajadores
extranjeros de menor cualificación de
sectores concretos quedarse en el país
durante cinco años en eso si no pueden
trasladar al país a sus familias la
segunda categoría permite a extranjeros
con formación más avanzada llevar a
japón a su familia y vivir por tiempo
indefinido convirtiendo su visión
permanente bajo ciertos criterios
en definitiva emigrar a japón es un
tormento a pesar de que necesitan gente
como agua de mayo y no lo digo por decir
para nada la despoblación que japón está
empezando a experimentar ya está
teniendo consecuencias más que notables
y eso que prácticamente acaba de
comenzar queréis saber más sobre los
problemas que el reto demográfico está
ocasionando ya en el país del sol
naciente pues atentos
[Música]
la catástrofe que se avecina
ah
os lo hace una pregunta sabéis que en
japón hay ni más ni menos que 800 96
ciudades y pueblos que se enfrentan a su
completa extinción para el año 2040 896
ciudades y pueblos y ojo que no se trata
de ninguna exageración periodística son
de hecho previsiones oficiales
previsiones realizadas por el instituto
nacional de investigaciones sobre
población y seguridad social un ente
afiliado al ministerio de salud trabajo
y bienestar del japón' y eso eso no es
todo el porcentaje de viviendas vacías
porque ya no hay gente interesada en
ocupar las quiero decir suponen ya el
13,5 por ciento de todas las viviendas
del país alrededor de 8 millones y medio
otro dato entre los años 2002 y 2017 en
japón se cerraron más de 7.000 colegios
públicos por falta de niños obviamente
todos estos problemas se concentran
principalmente en las zonas rurales que
están más alejadas de las principales
ciudades donde la población a pesar de
todo sigue enfrentándose en pequeños
apartamentos poco más grandes con ejerza
partos a precios desorbitados algo muy
diferente a lo que ocurría fuera de las
grandes metrópolis
la población agrícola puede ser un buen
ejemplo en 2015 de la zona como 75
millones de personas que se dedicaban a
la agricultura ni más ni menos que el 63
5% tenían más de 65 años un porcentaje
que se ha triplicado en tres décadas
amigos japón es el país con la relación
entre personas dependientes y personas
en mitad de trabajar más ajustada de
toda la ocde y para 2060 se espera que
el ratio llegue a un anciano por cada
persona necesita de trabajar una persona
uno-a-uno ya os podéis imaginar lo que
esto supone en materia de costes
sociales eso sí al menos el sistema de
pensiones japonés es mixto combina una
pensión asistencial pública con planes
de ahorros privados individuales esto se
traduce en que la pensión pública máxima
ojo máxima que puede cobrar un japonés
al jubilarse a los 65 años y tras
cotizar 40 años al plan nacional de
pensiones es de tan sólo seis mil
cuatrocientos euros anuales lo que
equivaldría a poco más de 530 euros al
mes en españa por ejemplo donde los
problemas demográficos no son muy
diferentes y el sistema de pensiones es
de reparto la pensión máxima supera los
37 mil euros anuales casi seis veces la
pensión máxima de japón así que ella os
podéis imaginar el escenario que se está
cocinando en españa- pero no nos
desviemos
por lo general existe cierto consenso en
torno a que una caída brusca de la
población conllevará también menos
trabajadores y por tanto una producción
inferior aunque con una fuerte inversión
en bienes de capital como maquinaria y
robots esto podría llegar a mitigarse al
menos esa es la esperanza de los
economistas japoneses pese a todo las
simulaciones económicas a largo plazo
realizadas en algunos estudios que
estiman que la debacle demográfica de
japón provocará una caída del pib
nacional del 20 por ciento durante el
próximo siglo en términos absolutos y en
torno a un 5% en términos per cápita
luego está la cuestión del gasto público
por ejemplo en 2018 el gasto sanitario
de japón alcanzó el 10,9 del pib y se
espera que para finales de esta década
ya suponga más del 12% esto es así
porque el gasto sanitaria está
íntimamente relacionado con la edad de
los pacientes por ejemplo para que os
hagáis una idea en japon el gasto
sanitario per cápita en menores de 75
años fue de unos 1.800 euros en 2018
mientras que los mayores de 75 años la
cifra se disparaba hasta los 7.600 euros
cuatro veces más en fin este es el
panorama demográfico al que se enfrenta
japón un país que en apenas una
generación va a perder casi una tercera
parte de su población y que va a tener
que lidiar con la evolución del pib a la
baja y mayores gastos sociales sobre los
cambios que están realizando para
adaptarse a este escenario os hablamos
ya con todo detalle en un pasado vídeo
en visual político os lo dejo por aquí
el enlace y también en la descripción la
cuestión ahora es qué solución puede
tener el colapso demográfico al que se
enfrenta el país terminará japón
convirtiéndose en uno de los países más
receptivos con la inmigración debido a
esta grave crisis que se les viene
encima
pues bien podéis dejarnos vuestras
opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y recordad si este vídeo os
ha gustado no olvidéis darle al botón de
like i suscribiros a visar politics si
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]